It's quickly become apparent that jared
cushner,
the 36 year old real estate investor and
husband,
that Ivanka trump is president donald
trump's most trusted advisor within his
inner circle,
a circle whose top tier includes chief
strategist,
Steve Bannon,
and chief of staff reince priebus.
Now it's pretty easy to know where
priebus and bannon stand politically as
chairman of the Republican National
Committee for five years.
Priebus is the voice of the Republican
establishment,
and as the former editor of Breitbart
bannon champions the populist economic
nationalism that appeal to so many of
trump's working class voters,
it's important to know where trump's key
advisors stand on the issues because
it's almost impossible to know where
trump himself stands.
Trump's not an idealogue.
He's a pragmatist who's changed his
views multiple times throughout the
years.
When it comes down to it,
his political goals are basically this.
We're going to win,
win,
win.
You're going to get so tired of winning.
You're going to say,
Mr.
President,
please.
We don't want to win anymore.
It's too much
evolved.
Trump's advisors tasks with this charge
of winning for the American people.
Jared cushner is the most important but
also the least understood.
We simply don't know where he stands
politically and there are a few reasons
for that.
Kushner is only 36 years old.
He's got no history in politics and it's
clear that even two or three years ago,
being a top advisor to the most powerful
man in the world wasn't remotely on his
radar,
is the last big project,
was buying this cluster of Brooklyn
buildings from the Jehovah's Witnesses
in 2013 for 375 million in order to turn
it into hipstery story,
office space,
Kushner,
and Ivanka too,
for that matter has always been a sort
of hybrid of the left leaning hipster
generation and the older mega rich
business elite.
Jared was certainly born into wealth and
lots of it,
but his family didn't start out that
way.
Both his paternal grandparents were
Holocaust survivors,
thankfully making it to the United
States.
In 1949 where Jerry's grandfather,
Joseph,
a construction worker,
started building and managing New Jersey
apartments.
His son,
jarrod's father Charles then started
acquiring real estate,
turning cushner companies his business
into a billion dollar empire.
This is the world that jared cushner
grew up in.
It was deeply religious.
Jarrod was brought up in modern Orthodox
Judaism,
massively wealthy and privileged.
Jared was conveniently accepted to
Hartford after his parents pledged two
point $5,000,000
to the university and actually quite
democratic.
Charles cushner was one of the most
prominent donors to democratic
politicians on the east coast.
In fact,
he was the largest single donor to the
2000 New York Senate campaign of Hillary
Clinton,
and then things came apart.
New Jersey based developer,
Charles cushner is charged with hiring a
prostitute to blackmail to witnesses and
a federal investigation where he is a
target.
Charles conviction was deeply traumatic
for charit as of course,
it would be a checkup his entire life
and not just emotionally,
but professionally too.
At the age of 24,
Jerry took over the massive empire,
his father bill,
and he wasted little time making a
splash of his own in 2007 cushner
companies bought an office building at
six,
six fifth avenue in Manhattan for one
point $8,
billion dollars,
the most expensive single building
purchase in US history.
Unfortunately,
it was really bad timing.
A year later,
the economy collapsed and six,
six,
six is not been able to generate enough
money for Kushner companies to pay off
the debt even today.
But despite that setback,
cushner kept at it.
He kept making deals or trying to like
the trendy tech office space in
Brooklyn.
It's clear that he's focused and driven
and ambitious,
but a success or failure in real estate
tells us preciously little about where
his mindset politically,
uh,
for all I know,
he could still sympathize with the
democratic values that his father funded
so generously,
but truth is Christian or seems a bit
out of place in the conservative
populist nationalist White House of
Donald Trump.
Until you account for two things.
First,
his loyalty to family cushner always
sticks by his own.
When his father was put away,
he didn't abandon him,
and when trump retweeted wittingly or
not,
some antisemitic imagery alongside a
picture of Hillary Clinton,
last summer,
cushing,
uh,
wrote an op Ed defending him in the New
York Observer,
the newspaper that he owns.
That's the second place to look for
hints of Kush nurse politics,
The Observer.
It was here that he developed a
friendship,
even a mentorship with Rupert Murdoch,
the media magnate and owner of Fox News,
Murdoch counsel,
jared gave him advice,
sent over books by prominent
conservative thinkers.
And soon the paper began to take on a
more right wing.
Then some say cushner even had a
vindictive streak using the paper to go
after people who wronged him or his
family.
Like,
for example,
New York attorney general,
Eric Schneiderman,
who investigated trump university.
The headpiece of the observer published
on Schneiderman is almost comical in
it's defense of trump scam school.
A lot of people saw this same
vindictiveness in the ouster of Chris
Christie from trump's transition team
last December.
Christie,
of course,
was the man who sent jerrod's father to
jail.
Mr Kushner engaged in a conspiracy with
co-conspirators.
It's a hire prostitutes.
This period is where cushner may have
begun to acquire more conservative
values,
but I have to be fair and say that these
are just inklings of what may be in his
mind.
He barely ever puts things on the
record.
He barely ever speaks to the media.
What we do know is that today cushner is
overseeing a laundry list of things in
trump's administration,
including heading the new office of
American innovation,
being the key liaison for diplomats from
China,
Mexico,
and a dozen other countries,
and of course there's this.
If you can produce peace in the Middle
East,
nobody can.
In most things,
trump and Kushner are opposites.
One is loud,
easily distracted and media obsessed.
The other is understated,
focused and media allergic,
but they both trust family and trump
definitely trusts jared cushner for
president with such little grasp on
policy and detail.
That means jared cushner might just be
the most influential person in the
world.
It would sure be nice to know a little
more about what people leaves.
Oh my God,
this couch is so comfortable.
Hey everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
Happy Wednesday.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes the process so simple.
If I can make a website on there,
which I did,
I guarantee you can too.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades.
Going to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
You can subscribe to this channel by
clicking the circle that's right over
there,
and you can watch the last episode about
Jack Nicholson and anger right there.
I think you'll really like it.
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.